so um what i'll do is i'll run through
this once if at any point you're like oh
no i missed the step
everything is different now maybe look
at the person next to you or at the end
if you're totally confused
this time i'll come and show you again
so first thing is turn your calculator
on
obviously and then what i want you to do
is at the top right i want you to hit
mode
okay when you hit mo it'll give you
these two options
um now if you've got a third one you
don't need to worry about it
um if you've got a c minus a plus
actually i wonder if i've got another
one in here
do you guys have a plus or a plus two
plus two oh here we go
yours is special okay i'll go with this
one because i think this one is closer
to the one you've got
okay so there's a plus two now when you
go mode okay there you go so is that the
third one you've got
yeah okay so don't worry about the third
one as you can guess the important one
for us is
stat for statistics okay i think one is
comp for computation
anyway it doesn't matter hit two then
this comes up and you're like whoa what
do i do with all this okay
don't have to worry too much about all
of them you want the first option and
this is probably worth writing down
maybe
i might just say this so your first step
was to hit mode
yeah you should this should ring some
bells the second thing was do you
remember we had to pick
two for stat
now this third step what you want is the
first option
one var it stands for one variable
by variable they mean like what scores
are you putting into this right
sometimes you want two scores matched up
together like someone's height and their
weight but at the moment like these are
just a set of numbers and that's all
so one variable so that's one so hit one
for me
and then this screen turns up okay
marvelous now
what you're looking at
did you hit one yeah interesting i'll
have a look at it later
if your screen deviates from mine
substantially then i'll come and have a
look at individually but i think most of
you should be looking at this
so what you've got is up the top there
you can see it says x so that's just the
name
of your variable like your score or
temperature or whatever
and then the one two three on the left
hand side is what's the score that
you're putting in the first second third
fourth okay
so all you have to do at this point is
punch in your numbers now
here's how you punch one in you type in
a number and then to enter that as the
first score you say equals
right so you can see it's going on the
first row 56 then 58 and hit equals
uh 74 hit equals you get the idea can
you punch them all in
so if you're done you should see i'm up
to um row 11 but i haven't put anything
in there because i've only got 10 scores
okay so that's fine you saved all of
that now you can press um
like press on to clear that all of that
data has been inputted
okay then i want you to see i'll just
move it temporarily down
here right if you see above the number
one there's a stat button
right and it's yellow so you got to get
press shift right
and then press one and then you've got
this new set of options here
okay now what you want to do you can do
a variety of things here we'll explore a
bit more of this menu but for now
you want to press four for var so maybe
what step are we up to
did you miss it no four really different
calculator
um after we hit one variable you then
enter all your data
you may want to go back to where you're
writing your steps you know if you get
this so
enter press numbers and then hit equals
okay after you do that you clear it
and then you say um shift one to get
into the options
that we're looking at right now shift
one um and
fires for very okay so yeah for far to
mean it's five so just five yep
okay so now you can see because our
screens are not the
greatest resolution right on my screen
it's option
three that that's lowercase sigma that i
showed you before
right so if i press three it's got that
lowercase
sigma and x i can do things with this
number if i want but all i want is the
number itself
so it's there and i just have to hit
equals
okay have you got the same number our
numbers match yeah yeah
which one of these three three just
still three yep
okay so what you've got now this number
is the standard deviation
eight point four seven eight dot dot dot
uh that should be okay so you just
calculated the standard deviation i'll
come to your calculator in a second
okay now just before we leave i want to
show you if you've entered your data
into stat mode there are a couple of
other handy things you can do with it
for instance clear it again clear it
again and again to explore these options
go
shift and then one to open up the stat
menu again
and i think if you go to five or
whichever option says min max
right you might recognize these what are
these guys
oh oh these are what will give you the
range and the interquartile range you've
got the
first quarter the lower quartile first
quartile you've got the median which is
the second one
and you've got quartile three now we
only inputted 10 of the scores right so
i'm not expecting that the median will
be the same
right but if i say equals then 59 is the
mean
of that top 10 scores right which is not
surprising i guess the bottom ten are
just a little bit different
okay um and you can calculate any of the
other things too if i go shift
one back to five you can work out the
first quartile
and it'll supply those numbers too
so again what that probably comes down
to is which calculator you've
got now i'm still going to say uh i
mentioned this before when someone else
asked me
you're like wait a second so does this
mean i never have to do
i rubbed it off i never have to do all
this fussing around with stem and leaf
plus to find the quartiles
the answer is yes and no okay here's my
um here's my warning
yes you can your calculator can do this
okay
do i recommend that you do it unless the
question specifically says to you
because there's like 50 scores here or
something like that
i wouldn't do it and here's why um what
are we trying to do
when we show you like a set of scores
like this or ask you to generate a
standard leaflet that kind of thing
we're trying to see do you understand
how to get the quarter
the number itself we don't care about we
want to see do you understand where the
number comes from
okay now one of the ways we will
hopefully don't assess that is if you
get it correctly
but suppose you get your like maybe you
just you know
it's pretty easy to just miss a number
right you're like oh i put in or i put
in 73 instead of 72 or whatever it is
and then you go ahead and you do fully
press all your buttons
and then out pops a single number and
maybe your number is off by one
and that's all there is on the page what
am i going to be able to do as a marker
in terms of assessing how much does this
student understand
and the answer is not very much right
that could be a guess or someone could
eat rolling dice for all i know right
that number just by itself even though
it came from here
it doesn't demonstrate understanding if
it's wrong okay so
i wouldn't i mean you can use it to
double check this is a little bit like
when i teach g7
you do fractions you've got to know how
to do them mentally go ahead
check it with this but don't rely on
this okay you have to be able to do it
yourself you're all your calculator is
still in stat mode yeah still in stat
mode
what i want you to do is i want you to
press a few extra buttons with me so
instead of saying mode to go to stat
mode or whatever i want you to get
whoa careful sorry that's all right i
want you guys shift
mode that'll put you into setup okay um
you press down don't you
nick yeah press down press down okay if
you're in this screen you press down
and you can see if you press three
you can change some options for stat
this is what you'll get
now at the moment everyone's frequency
is well almost everyone's frequency is
off i want you to press one and turn it
on okay
now so far nothing looks different i
want you to go
uh there's a couple ways to do this you
can press shift one stat
you can press two to get back to your
data you'll notice it's all cleared out
i think
i think it should be cleared out okay
and you have an extra column on the
right hand side
okay now what do you think that
indicates
okay so it's like how many times this
score come up now have a look see this
one right
each of the scores comes up just once i
can still do this i can still go
uh 56 equals 58
equals and so on right that's all fine
okay
but if i want to say actually you know
what
i i don't have just one person who
scored 50 56
i actually have 20 of them right rather
than saying 56
and punching in 20 times i can just
adjust the frequency
and um and i'm done right i can now yes
super great right
i can now go shift one uh four for
variable standard deviation
and say equals and i get my number out
just like before okay